an immigrant peter thiel came to the
united states he's born i believe in
hungary
came to the united states
and built a life
of wealth happiness and financial
security from germany he's from germany
okay
we should celebrate the fact that this
immigrant
entrepreneur and investor has been
successful this is the american dream
realized
and so
it recently came out that peter thiel
who not only built paypal he's
co-founder of palantir he's been an
investor in facebook and hundreds of
other companies have been highly highly
successful
has five billion dollars in his roth ira
and of course the second that anyone
inside of the government here's that
somebody was successful what do they
have to do they gotta go try to change
the rules
and so
first let's talk about how an ira works
if you remember a traditional ira along
with a traditional 401k style workplace
retirement account which works similarly
and can be rolled over into an ira takes
pre-tax dollars meaning before their tax
the dollars go in by contributing you
lower your tax bill and the accounts can
be invested and grow tax-free at least
for a while at some point starting at
age 72 at the latest you need to start
tapping your traditional ira and those
withdrawals get taxed as income to you
once an investment inside a roth ira
account your gains are never taxed as
long as you live even after you die your
hairs get to live off a roth iras
tax-free bounty for a decade so there's
multiple kinds of retirement accounts
you can have the traditional ira where
pre-tax dollars go in you also can have
post-stack tax dollars go into some of
these accounts now what peter did was
peter put
contributions in some of those
contributions included shares that he
had bought of paypal which ended up
going on to being a multi-billion dollar
company
today
in recent days
a tax plan that has been approved by the
house ways and means committee includes
limits on their use by the wealthy
including a provision that would impose
restrictions on retirement accounts
whose value exceeds 10 million dollars
now peter thiel
is the ira king according to john he's
just the king of iras he has amassed
five billion dollars in a roth
of feet accomplished by placing his
paypal shares in the account in 1999
when it was a private company and within
a year their value jumped from 1664
to 3.8 million dollars the company
became more valuable
over time they grew and grew and grew
into now billions of dollars
but the general premise of these new
rules is that account holders must
withdraw fifty percent of the accounts
valued at more than ten million dollars
larger accounts must also draw down 100
percent of roth account size over 20
million dollars so somebody like peter
would have to go and take the 5 billion
dollars in his roth ira and take out all
of it but 20 million dollars now why do
they want him to take it out why do they
want to force him to take it out well
because of course they're going to tax
him they're going to take it from him
and so what we are literally watching in
real time
is
somebody who has been on one side of the
political aisle
that is now having the other side of the
political aisle create rules targeted
specifically at an individual like this
in order to confiscate their wealth
that's what we're watching here we can
call it whatever we want but the fact is
people got pissed because the news broke
that somebody had a lot of money in the
roth ira and so they now are stepping in
and they're literally creating a rule
around it in order to get this
individual to get the money out so that
the government can then come in and take
it
now
it is not just one individual there are
29 000 americans that have an ira worth
5.5 million dollars or more
500 americans have an ira worth 25
million dollars or more and one in four
americans have no savings for retirement
so there's a very very big distribution
here obviously 25 of americans have no
savings for retirement 29 000 americans
have 5 million or more in their ira so
we're talking about is going to affect a
very small portion of the population but
it is still the spirit of the rule that
seems wrong now we have a quote from
robert keebler who by the way just gets
internet points for having an awesome
name robert keebler and he said if teal
is really clever and can get his
adjusted gross income below the
threshold he will avoid this new rule
altogether so i believe the key is that
in order for there to be
some sort of distribution or withdrawal
from the roth ira
under these new rules you have to have
an income over 400 000
so if you showed up and you said oh i
only make 250 000
they can't make you then take out the
money so it's specifically targeting
people with high income over 400 000
and people with large roth iras now when
we look at the
pro-publica article that broke this news
they didn't do any favors because they
posted it and the title was the lord of
the roths
which played into a whole bunch of
different social thought processes
around wealth and the condemnation
of wealth now on top of that we've got
this chart here that shows exactly what
happened with the roth so you can see
there that the roth account was opened
in 1999 it used he used it to buy
founders shares by the way they write
dirt cheap no that was just what the
price of the founders shares were it's
not like he got a discount from the
other founders shares he didn't go and
negotiate 50 off at the department store
that's what the price of the founder
shares were at the end of the year the
account is worth 1 664
makes sense
by the time
that we see it continue to grow and you
can see it's gone up and down in value
it has not just gone up over time it's
been volatile
that
his roth is worth five billion dollars
now if an ordinary person had maxed out
their roth contributions every year
since 1999 in a standard s p 500 index
fund they would only have about 260 000
so what becomes fascinating about this
is if you simply put your roth
contributions in for 20 years and you
invested in the s p 500 you would end up
with a quarter of a million dollars
that's not even enough to live on for
most people if you retire at 62 you're
supposed to live to 80.
you literally can't retire at 62 and
live until you're 77 78 whatever the
life expectancy is today
on 250 000 for the average person
so the existing benchmark that we use
does not work in terms of how retirement
is supposed to happen
so what we are looking at is somebody
who's obviously a good investor forget
the roth ira like peter thiel has done
fantastic as have many others
but we've also lived over the last 11
years in one of the greatest bull
markets in history
and so when you have the stock market
going up 20 30 40
year after year after year after year
for a decade
and people are invested in the stock
market in their retirement accounts
there is obviously going to be a lot of
money that ends up in those accounts
forget the outliers 29
000 americans have five million dollars
or more now you may look at that and say
wow how did they get five million
dollars in there
but if you simply started with
somewhere around 250 or 500 000
and you did that back in 2000
when you were 30 years old
and over time you have watched as the
stock market has grown and grown and
grown by the time you had a million
dollars in there and then all of a
sudden the stock market went up 30 in a
year by the end of the year you have 1.3
million and then if the stock market
goes up another 20
you now have over 1.5 million
and this continues year after year after
year after year until now you're sitting
there and you've got over five million
dollars in your roth ira
that person isn't trying to do anything
elicit they're not trying to do anything
nefarious they simply are saying tell me
the rules and i will do what i'm
supposed to do within those rules now
what i don't like is that somehow people
are saying well we don't like the
outcome of those rules so let's change
the rules
but they want to do it retroactively
they want to do it to punish people not
necessarily to say hey
we believe that these rules worked up
until now but we're going to change the
rules and now if we change the rules
going forward this will affect anybody i
should be okay with that i don't like
the fact that they want to change the
rules but if they want to change the
rules and they want to implement it
correctly
that's their right we elect people they
go into office they're there to
represent the will of the people and if
that's what they choose to do that's
what they choose to do that is the
beauty of a democracy
but to say we are going to retroactively
put this in place and we are going to
punish people who have been successful
in the existing system feels a little
weird of course why do they want the
money simple they have a huge tax plan
they want to spend the money
and so if you were to ask me would i
rather joe biden or peter thiel to have
five billion dollars to spend i would
much rather peter thiel have the money
than joe biden
by the way if it was donald trump or any
other president i would say the exact
same thing the government officials
don't seem so good at investing capital
compared to some of the top investors on
wall street or in venture capital
silicon valley etc so regardless of
which political party is in power or
which administration is actually there
i would rather the capital being in the
hands of the entrepreneurs and the
investors who are financially
incentivized to invest in technology
to continue to push the pace of
innovation
and so when we look at the actual
retirement inequality we have a chart
here that shows
the average u.s retirement savings
account balances by net worth percentile
and so the bottom 25
according to the federal reserve survey
of consumer finances
basically has nothing they have no
retirement at all
if you then look at the
bottom or the 25 to 50
percentile they have just a little bit
more than nothing so they have some
retirement but nothing that is actually
material but then look at the 50 to 75
percent again not so much and then if
you look at the 75 to 90 percent they
also have somewhere in that 250 000
range it is not enough to retire on at
the age of 62 and live to 77 or 78 years
old you were talking about 15 years
of living on 250 000 in totality and if
you have only been able to grow it to
250 000 by the time you retire you are
unlikely to all of a sudden turn your
250 000 into a couple of million dollars
you do not have the
mindset you do not have the skill set or
the experience in investing to take that
250 000 and somehow all of a sudden grow
it significantly so what happens is that
90
or more of the average u.s retirement
savings do not have enough money in it
for the individual to retire today and
live from 62 to 77 or 78 years old now
the top 10 percent
they have significant amounts in their
retirement
what i personally believe is that we
should go to that top 10 percent and we
should say
how did you do it
what did you do walk us through exactly
what you did and then we should take
that information and we should go and we
should tell every single american here
is how you can get in a position where
you will have enough money when you
retire so that you are not dependent on
a social security system that we know is
supposed to run out of money within the
next 12 or 13 years so you are not
dependent on your government stepping in
and saving you
rather than condemning success what we
should look at is we should go and we
should learn and we should take the
knowledge of those who have figured it
out and we should turn around and as
part of a nationwide personal finance
and financial education program we
should teach the bottom 90 of people who
right now will not have enough money to
retire how to do it we should celebrate
success we should use the education as
an opportunity to get more people in a
better position rather than simply say
let's take from those that have and then
what we will do is we will give it to
the government and the government will
do who knows what as we talked about
that big infrastructure plan that they
want to pay for we went through it they
want to buy weed to study driving high
and they want to look at invasive plant
species removal programs so not exactly
going to help the 90 of americans or so
that don't have enough money to retire
what's up guys bang bang your boy pomp
thanks so much for watching the best
business show our goal is to make this
the largest most actionable business
show in the world and to do that we need
your help we've partnered with sofi as
our exclusive sponsor because they have
a piece of software that we think will
help you take the information that we
share on a daily basis and make it
actionable we want every single person
to pursue and achieve financial security
and financial freedom in order to do
that you gotta act and sofi allows you
to do it so you can go to sofi.com pomp
today you can open up an account and
when you open up an account you can
invest in all sorts of different types
of assets etfs individual stocks ipos
bitcoin cryptocurrencies they even have
an automated investing function if you
want to invest sofi can help you they've
got a couple of different offers that
you can benefit from the first open an
invest account and they'll give you up
to a thousand bucks for free kind of a
no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right so far doesn't care
where your current account is but if you
transfer it from that place to sofi
they'll pay you up to five thousand
dollars for doing it why wouldn't you do
it it's up to five thousand dollars for
free head on over to sofi.com today to
get started and come back tomorrow and
watch more of the best business show
together we're gonna build the biggest
show in the world
[Music]